ALAN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BELL. GORGEOUS BRADFORD
CAPPIELLO CHANG DALLY DOT THERE
ALSO YEAH JOHNNY GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG HILL
WITH SO TADO JACKSON JONES
LLEVA MCGUIRE. MITCHELL MINING
MORE LOCKED. RAIL NELSON PAN
FORTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN STONE NUMBER WHY CASKEY
WINNER WILL. COLLEAGUES A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS SHOULD OUR GUESTS
BEHIND AND BEYOND THE RAIL ANY
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE
WILL BE LET IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING AND WE
WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. BY
SENATOR ROTH. SO LET'S TAKE A
MOMENT TO REMEMBER THAT'S WHERE
IN GOD'S PRESENCE. THIS IS
CALLED THE SONG OF THE BUILDERS
BY MARY OLIVER. I THINK SOME OF
YOU HAVE HEARD IT BEFORE. ON A
SUMMER MORNING I SAT DOWN ON
THE HILLSIDES TO THINK ABOUT
GOD. THEY WERE THE PASTIME.
NEAR ME I SAW A SINGLE CRICKETS.
IS WAS MOVING THE GRAINS ON THE
HILLSIDES THIS WAY AND THAT WAY.
HOW GREAT WAS ITS ENERGY HOW
HUMBLE ITS EFFORTS. LET US HOPE
IS WILL ALWAYS BE LIKE THIS
EACH OF US GOING ON IN OUR
INEXPLICABLE WAYS BUILDING THE
UNIVERSE. CREATOR OF MYSTERY
AND WONDER GRANTS THAT THIS DAY
WE MAY GO ABOUT OUR WORK WITH
THE HUMBLE EFFORTS OF THE
CRICKETS AND THE JOY OF BEING
HUMAN. AMEN. WHY OKAY YEAH. AND
MY NATION UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE.
WITH LIBERTY YEAH FOR ALL. IS
THIS A GREAT HAVE A GOOD READ.
GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES. WE
WILL NOW PROCEED WITH
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. SEEING
NONE WE WILL MOVE TO MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE
DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED FRED
REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED READ AN AMENDMENT
ADOPTED UNDER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. MOVING
ON TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. UNDER SECOND
READING FILE MR SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
340-240-1190. 1-174-076-2912 OH
NINE SECOND READING WILL BE
DEEMED FRED MOVING ON NOW
COLLEAGUES TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS WE ARE GOING TO START
WITH FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE. AND
WE WILL GO THROUGH THE FILE ONE
TIME AND THEN PLACE THESE ITEMS
ON CALL. AND I WILL SO ADVISE
WHEN WE WILL CHANGE THAT
PROCESS BUT FOR NOW WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY NINE SENATOR DODD. ARE
YOU READY TO PROCEED VERY GOOD
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
THE BILL NINETEEN BY SENATOR
DODD AN ACT RELATING TO WATER
RESOURCES SENATOR DODD. MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I PRESENTING
SP NINETEEN PERTAINING TO
STREAM GAGES THIS BILL AS
AMENDED ASSEMBLY THERE'S A
STRONG COALITION OF SUPPORT NO
OPPOSITION. IKE ASTRAKHAN KIRK
THE ASSEMBLY MA'AM. THANK YOU
SENATOR DODD DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. THE
BAIT OR DISCUSSION. SEEING AND
HEARING ON MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALAN.
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES. BELL
HI PORGES. NO HI. I CARRY IT
ALL. CHANG. DALLY HI DON I'D
RATHER. I GOT JOHNNY BY GLAZER
I GONZALEZ. GROVE HERTZBERG.
GROW BY. HILL. HIGHWAY SO HI
TADO. JACKSON BY JONES LEVA
TIME ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL. BY
MORNING BUY MORE LARK I'M A
REAL BY NELSON. AND. HI PORT TO
TINO. HI ROSS. BY RUBIO BY
SKINNER. BY STERN HI STONE BY
AMBERG. HI BY KELSEY. BY WINNER
I WILL BY SENATOR. SENATE
SENATOR DODD MOVES A CALL WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON NOW TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY THREE SENATORS
SKINNER ARE YOU PREPARED TO
TAKE UP THIS ITEM. ALL RIGHT
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE
COLLEAGUES MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL THREE
THIRTY BY SENATOR SKINNER AN
ACRYLATE HOUSING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SIGNED BY. HAPPY TO BE
PRESENTING THIS BILL TO YOU FOR
CONCURRENCE IT RECEIVED SIXTY
SEVEN VOTES ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR YESTERDAY IT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO HELP US
ADDRESS THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
AN EXTREME HOUSING SHORTAGE IN
CALIFORNIA IN FACT CALIFORNIA
HAS D. LOWEST NUMBER OF UNITS
PER CAPITA. HOUSING UNITS IN
THE US AND THAT SCARCITY HAS
IMPACTED THE HIGH COST SIR OR
HE WILL LEAD TO THE HIGH COST
OF HOUSING THAT WE EXPERIENCE
WITH SOME OF THE HIGHEST HOME
PURCHASING PROCESS PRICES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY RIGHT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. AND THIRTY THREE
OF THE FIFTY CITIES WITH THE
HIGHEST RENTS ARE ALL OF RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO WHAT IS
SB THREE THIRTY DO IT JUST SAYS
IF YOU ARE APPLYING FOR A
PERMIT FOR HOUSING THAT ALREADY
MEETS THE GOVERNMENT ZONING AND
DESIGN REVIEW GOALS TO IT
ALREADY SIX THIS MORNING
EXISTING DESIGN REVIEW IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE VARIANCES. THAT
ONCE THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS
DEEMED YOUR APPLICATION
COMPLETE THEY WOULD SPEED UP
THE PROCESSING OF THAT
APPLICATION AND DURING THE
PERIOD OF TIME WHERE THEY ARE
NOT PROCESSING THEY WOULD NOT
CHANGE THE RULES OR INCREASED
FEEDS ON YOUR OUT PATIENT. SO
THAT'S WHAT IT DOES IT EXISTS
FOR ONLY FIVE YEARS AS A SUNSET
IN FIVE YEARS IT. IS ORDERED BY
BLOWING BUSING COMMUNITY. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT QUESTION
FOR THE AUTHOR WOULD YOU ACCEPT
THE QUESTION SENATOR SKINNER.
WOULD YOU ACCEPT THE QUESTION
YES I JUST QUESTION ON THE
PARKING REQUIREMENTS I NOTICE
THE MINISTRY MOVE THOSE HOWEVER
MY QUESTION IS WHETHER WE ARE
STILL TIED TO THE DENSITY BONUS
REQUIREMENTS AND I DON'T
REMEMBER WE ARE DELIGHTED TO
WHICH- TO THE DENSITY BONUS
REQUIREMENTS THAT WERE IN A
ANOTHER OF THE HOUSING BILLS
AND I'M SORRY THE- ACTUAL BILL
NUMBER ESCAPES ME BUT DENSITY
BONUSES ARE BEING GIVEN. TO
DEVELOPERS FOR INCREASING
HOUSING AND WITHOUT A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WOULD BE REQUIRED
TO. READ REMOVE PARKING
REQUIREMENTS OF WIND AND THEY
GIVE THE DENSITY BONUS I DON'T
THINK THEY HAVE AN OPTION
ACTUALLY NOT TO GIVE THE
DENSITY BONUS AND WITH THAT YOU
CAN REMOVE PARKING. FIVE
PERMISSION ANSWER CERTAIN. I'M
I APPRECIATE YOUR RACING A
COUPLE OF THOSE QUESTIONS FIRST
OFF. IN TERMS OF ANY NEW BILLS
THAT WE MIGHT PASS THIS YEAR.
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT LIVE YET.
I CAN'T. ANSWER AND ANALYZE
WHAT THEIR IMPACT MAYBE ON THIS
BUT WHAT I CAN SAY IS THE BILL
THAT WAS ORIGINALLY BEFORE THIS
HOUSE. WHICH DID PASS OUR FLOOR
HAD PROVISIONS SUCH AS. LIFTING
OR SUSPENDING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
MINIMUM PARKING REQUIREMENTS
THAT IS BEEN REMOVED THAT IS NO
LONGER IN THIS BILL. IT WAS
ALSO IN THE ORIGINAL BILL.
VISIONS THAT WOULD HAVE
SUSPENDED FOR JUST THE FIVE
YEARS THE BILL WAS IN THE FACT.
THINGS LIKE VOTER APPROVAL FOR
ZONING CHANGES AND OTHER VOTER
APPROVAL MEASURES THAT HAS BEEN
AMENDED OUT SO THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED QUITE A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS AND MOST
OF THE ISSUES THAT WHEN YOU SEE
THE LIST OF CITIES THAT OPPOSE
THE BILL IF YOU LOOK AT THEIR
LETTERS AND YOU SEE WHAT IT IS
THAT THEY WERE OPPOSING THEY
WERE OPPOSING EITHER THE FACT.
THAT THERE WAS LIFTING OF
MINIMUM PARKING REQUIREMENTS OR
THAT IT THE BILL MIGHT HAVE
OVER RIDDEN VOTER APPROVAL
REQUIREMENTS ALL OF THOSE
THINGS HAVE BEEN REMOVED THEY
ARE NO LONGER THERE AND THE
CITIES THAT HAVE CAREFULLY RE
LOOKED AT THE BILL THAT IS
BEFORE YOU. THEY WILL SEE THAT
WHAT THEY HAD OBJECTED TO IS NO
LONGER IN THE BILL AND I THINK
THAT IS ONE OF THE REASONS YOU
SAW A SIGNIFICANT VOTE ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR DESPITE SOME OF
THOSE CITIES OPPOSITION. AND IN
MANY OF THE CITIES THAT MY
STAFF AND I HAVE SPOKEN TO
PERSONALLY ONCE WE WENT THROUGH
THE SPECIFICS OF THE BILL THEY
ADMITTED THAT YES IT NO LONGER
HAS THE THINGS THAT WE WERE
MOST CONCERNED ABOUT. SO THIS
BILL IS A VERY DIFFERENT FORM
THAN IT WAS BEFORE YOU IT STILL
HAS SOME VERY IMPORTANT OF
PROVISIONS THAT WILL ALLOW US
TO HELP GET THE OWNING THAT
ALREADY MEETS LOCAL RULES.
PERMITTED A LITTLE BIT FASTER.
AND CERTAINTY TO THE PERSON TO
THE APPLICANT SO THAT THE
APPLICANT KNOWS THAT DURING THE
TIME THE PERMIT IS BEING
PROCESSED THE RULES ARE CHANGED
AND FEES AREN'T RACIST. THANK
YOU OUR MAN I THINK I AM GOING
TO BE IN A SUPPORT ON THEIR
STAND WITH ALL THOSE MINUTES
THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
SENATOR SKINNER YOU MAY CLOSE.
I APPRECIATE THE ABILITY TO
GIVE MORE EXPLANATION TO THE
BILL SO I APPRECIATE THAT
QUESTION. AND I ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED
MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ALAN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
BY BATES. BELL I PURCHASED
BRADFORD HI. CAPPIELLO I CHANGE
I DELI GOT A FULL DAUGHTER DELI
I. HI TODD. DEROSA HI. YEAH
JOHNNY HI GLAZER. GONZALEZ
GROVE. HERTZBERG BY HILL I WISH
SO I OR TITLE I JACKSON. JONES
THEY HAVE A. I AM A CHOIR HI
MITCHELL. BY MONEY HI MORLOCK
MORALE. NELSON PAN. HI PARDON
DO YOU KNOW HI HI ROSS BY RUBIO.
HI SKINNER I STERN BY STONE NO
NUMBER. IA CATHY BYE WINNER BY
WILL NO. SENATOR SKINNER MOVED
TO CALL WE'RE GOING TO PROCEED
NOW BACK TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
FILE ITEM THIRTY. SENATOR
WINNER MR SECRETARY PLEASE READ
IN ABOUT FORTY BY SENATOR
WINNER AN ACT RELATING TO
MENTAL HEALTH AND CLEAN THERE'S
THROUGHOUT THE TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR WINNER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT CALLING SO I SENATE
BILL FORTY IS A FOLLOW UP BILL
TO SENATE BILL TEN FORTY FIVE
FROM LAST YEAR THAT I JOIN
AUTHORED ALONG WITH CENTER THIS
CENTER FROM LOS ANGELES.
ASSEMBLY MA'AM AND SO I MADE
IMPORTANT TECHNICAL AND
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES TO THE BILL
INCLUDING STRENGTHENING THE
FUNCTION OF THE HOUSING
CONSERVATORSHIP PROGRAM FURTHER
SAFEGUARDS FOR THE CIVIL
LIBERTIES SECONDS OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE CONCERNED INCREASING
REPORTING TO THE COURTS AND
INCREASING INFORMATION
GATHERING TO INSURE THAT WE
LEARN FROM THIS LIMITED PILOT
PROGRAM. THESE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ALSO CREATE
IMPORTANT SAFEGUARDS AROUND THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE
CONSERVATIVE PROGRAM TO BALANCE
THE RESPECT FOR INDIVIDUAL
CIVIL LIBERTIES WHILE
RECOGNIZING THE DIRE SITUATIONS
THAT ALL TOO MANY CALIFORNIANS
FACE ON OUR STREETS AROUND
SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE. CHALLENGES ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AIBO.
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON FILE
ITEM THIRTY. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALAN. ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS I BASE BY BILL BURGESS
BY BRADFORD I CARRY IT ALL HI
JANE I DALLY IDOT EITHER
ALTHOUGH. DOES JOHNNY. BY
GLAZER BY GONZALEZ. GROWTH BY
HERZBERG BY HILL HIGHWAY SO I
OR TITLE HI JACKSON. JONES
LABOR. I'M ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL
BY MONEY ARE MORE LOCK I'M REAL
HI NELSON. I PAN. SPORTS DO YOU
KNOW. HI. ROSS I RUBIO I
SKINNER BY STERN I STONE. I
AMBERG OUR CASKEY HI WINNER I
WILL. CALL HI COLLEAGUES WE NOW
HAVE A FULL HOUSE SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE ROLE
ONE MORE TIME AND THEN WE WILL
CLOSE OUT THE ROLE ON FILE ITEM
THIRTY SO IF YOU WOULD MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN TIRADO.
GUNS GONZALEZ HI JACKSON I
JONES PAN PAN I. ONE MORE TIME
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALAN HI DRAWS OF JONES. ALL
EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON
THE URGENCY ICE THIRTY EIGHT
OUR NOSE ZERO. ON THE- BILL AT
HAND ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING ON NOW TO.
FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR UNDER
SENATE THIRD READING FILE ITEM
FORTY FOUR SENATOR WAY SO. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION FORTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR WAY SO RELATIVE TO
COMMERCE SENATOR WAY SO. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SP THREE
THREE EIGHT IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE FROM THE ASSEMBLY
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR DISABILITY
JUSTICE ACT WHICH WILL GIVE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
TOOLS TO BETTER PROTECT. SENIOR
CITIZENS IN CALIFORNIA'S LIVING
WITH DISABILITIES. FROM ABUSE
SEXUAL ASSAULT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HATE CRIMES AND
MURDER. ASSEMBLY IN MEN MEN'S
AT HUMAN TRAFFIC INTO THE LIST
OF CRIME THIS BILL PLIES TOO
AND DEFINES HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND ALSO CHANGE THE SENATOR
RATIO IT THIS IS. SENATE ROOMS
ARE IN FORTY EIGHT SO WILL.
SCRATCH THAT AND WE WERE WE
WERE AN ITEM THIRTY I FILED
THIRTY FOUR WAS I'LL ITEM FORTY
FOUR SOLDIERS AROUND. WE'RE
JUMPING AROUND ON THE FILE.
YEAH PART THAT ITEM IS UNDER
PROPOSED SPECIAL CONSENT SO
LET'S GO BACK OKAY ALL RIGHT SO
YOU'VE WON ON THAT ONE SO BEST
TO THANK YOU GO BACK IN AND
START ON FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR
SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY EIGHT.
OKAY MADAM PRESIDENT THANK FOR
SURE I APPRECIATE THE UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL VOTE ON THAT BILL.
PROUD TO PRESENT SP FORTY EIGHT
IT'S AN IMPORTANT RESOLUTION
WHICH URGES THE LEADERS OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO ACTIVELY
OPPOSE AND AVOID ANY TERROR
TARIFFS LEVIED ON MEXICAN
GOODS. EARLIER THIS YEAR
PRESIDENT TRUMP ANNOUNCES PLAN
TO IMPOSE A FIVE PERCENTER OF
ON MEXICAN GOODS GRADUALLY
INCREASING AS MUCH AS- UP 225%
WHICH WAS SET TO TAKE EFFECT ON
JUNE TENTH TWENTY NINETEEN.
TERRORISTS WERE CONTINUED ON
THE FLOW OF IMMIGRANTS TO THE
UNITED STATES ON UNTIL MEXICO
SUBSTANTIALLY SLOWED
IMMIGRATION TEARS WOULD REMAIN
IN PLACE ALTHOUGH SUCH TARIFFS
HAVE SINCE BEEN. INDEFINITELY
SUSPENDED. V. AMBIGUITY AND
UNCERTAINTY REGARDING THEIR
ENFORCEMENT SHOULD BE A CAUSE
FOR CONCERN FOR THE ECONOMIC
WELL BEING OF CALIFORNIA FREE
TRADE BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND
MEXICO A PRODUCT OF THE NORTH
ATLANTIC FREE TRADE AGREEMENT.
PLAYED AN INTEGRAL ROLE IN
BUILDING CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
TO BECOMING THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD I OFTEN
TELL PEOPLE. THAT CALIFORNIA
AND MEXICO BUILD THINGS
TOGETHER WE DON'T BUILD THINGS
INDEPENDENTLY OR ECONOMIES HAVE
BECOME INTERWOVEN. AND
TERRORISTS ON MEXICAN GOODS
OFTENTIMES WILL RESULT IN
BECOMING A TERRIFYING
CALIFORNIA ME GOODS AS WELL.
SERVICE LIVE IT ON MEXICO WOULD
BE DETRIMENTAL TO BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA JOB MARKET AND THE
ECONOMY IF TERRORISTS WERE
IMPOSED APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
THOUSAND JOBS IN CALIFORNIA
WOULD BE LOST. NEARLY SIX
HUNDRED NINETY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF EXPORTS TO
MEXICO WOULD BE TARGETED TO
TRADE RETALIATION. TO PRESERVE
CALIFORNIA'S LONGSTANDING AND%
LUCRATIVE RELATIONSHIP WITH
MEXICO AND TO ENSURE ECONOMIC
SUCCESS RESULTING FACTOR FREE
TRADE. FOR BOTH OF OUR STATE
NATION WE MUST URGE THE LEADERS
OF OUR COUNTRY TO AVOID LIVING
TERRACE ON MEXICO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPOD
TODAY THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SENATOR
HUESO DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
DEBATER DISCUSSIONS SENATOR
GROVE. I'M SORRY SENATOR
NIELSEN YOU HAVE YOUR MIKE UP
AS WELL WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO
AHEAD AND START. THAT ADDRESS
DELAYS GEM THE SENATE ARJUN I'D
VOTE. YOU KNOW THE TWO
COUNTRIES ARE INDEED
INSEPARABLE TRADING PARTNERS.
HISTORIC PARTNERSHIPS AND
RELATIONSHIPS. AND SUCCESSFULLY
THE TWO NATIONS THAT NEED RE
NEGOTIATED THE NAFTA AGREEMENT
OF LONG TIME AGO. I'M OF THE
OPINION THAT DIDN'T NEED SOME
CHANGES. THE POINT BEING THAT
THE TWO COUNTRIES CAME TOGETHER
AND WORK TOGETHER FOR THE BEST
INTEREST OF BOTH COUNTRIES. AND
WHAT DOES NOT SUIT US TO GET
INTO A TRADE WAR. WITH MEXICO I
HOPE WE CAN AVOID THAT IT LOOKS
LIKE WE HAVE THUS FAR. VIRGIN I
WILL. THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN
CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I TO RISE IN A
SUPPORT IS GONE I THINK THE
AUTHOR THIS IS WHERE THE IDEA
CAME FROM FOR THE US MCA. AND
THE ONLY THING THAT WE DID WAS
ADD CANADA TO THAT BECAUSE
CANADA AND MEXICO ARE EQUAL
TRADING PARTNERS AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT. THAT THREE
COUNTRIES WORK VERY VERY WELL
TOGETHER AND SO I APPLIED THE
AUTHOR FOR MAKING SURE THAT
THIS COMES FORWARD AND I THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR SUPPORTING THE
US MCA WHICH GOT OFF THE FLOOR
LAST WEEK. AND I THINK THIS IS
VERY RELEVANT TO TRADE AND
ECONOMIC VIABILITY FOR
CALIFORNIA AND CANADA ALSO IS
THAT OF. A GOOD TRADING PARTNER
OF ARE SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO'D LIKE TO
COMMENT ON THIS LOVE FEST.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
WAY SO YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT OF I REQUEST A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL VOTE IN
THIS BILL THANK YOU. ALL THE
BIG HAVING CEASE MR SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS HI BATES HI
BILL I BURGESS. BRADFORD I
CARRY AT ALL I CHAIN HI DOLLY.
DOT. I'D RATHER GO I GOT JOHNNY
I GLAZER BY GONZALES HIGH
GROWTH I HURTS BERG I HILL I
WAS SO TIRED TADO I JACKSON BY
JONES LABOR TIME ACQUIRE HI
MITCHELL. BY MONEY. BUY MORE
LUCK. MORALE NELSON. I PAN HI
FORTINO BY ROTH I RUBIO BY
SKINNER. BY STERN BY STONE.
NUMBER OUR CASSIE BY WINNER BY
WILKE HI. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS GORGEOUS DELHI.
JONES MORLOCK. MORE LIKE I.
MERRELL STONE. BY AGE THIRTY
FIVE NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING NOW TO FILE ITEM FORTY
SIX. FILE ITEM FORTY SIX CENTER
WAY SO THAT IS ALSO YOUR ITEM.
ARE YOU PREPARED TO PROCEED MR
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION FIFTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR WAY SO RELATIVE TO THE
TIJUANA RIVER. SENATOR WAY SO
THANK YOU AND PRESIDENT SR
FIFTY SEVEN IS A RESOLUTION THE
SIXTY SIX TO EXPAND ON
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL NEEDED
RELIEF TO COMMUNITY THAT HAS
BEEN PLAGUED BY A LONG STANDING
POLLUTION PROBLEM IN THAT THE
ONE A RIVER VALLEY. MEMBERS AS
MESSED MANY OF YOU KNOW. HAVING
BEEN AT THIS FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS TO DECLINE A
RIVER VALLEY IS AN ISSUE. THAT
OF HAS BEEN PLAGUING MY
COMMUNITY FOR MANY YEARS FOR
MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS. THIS
RIVER VALLEY HAS EXPERIENCED AN
INCREASE THIS CHARGE OF TRASH
SENTIMENT WASTE WATER. AND EVEN
SOME VEHICLES HAVE COME IN FROM
MEXICO THROUGH THE RIVER. WITH
PEOPLE IN SOME INSTANCES. AND
THIS THIS CHARGE OF RAW SEWAGE
AND OTHER WASTE AND EVERYTHING
CONCEIVABLE THAT COULD POSSIBLY
COME IN THROUGH THIS LARGE
RIVER BODY. POSES A SERIOUS
PUBLIC HEALTH RISK FROM
UNTREATED AND PARTIALLY TREATED
HUMAN AND INDUSTRIAL WASTE
WATER THAT CONTAINS TOXINS
BACTERIAL VIRAL PATHOGENS HE
COLI. VIBRIO AND SOLOMON ALLAH
IS INCLUDING PLASTICS. AND
STYROFOAM AND EVERYTHING YOU
CAN IMAGINE THIS HAS BEEN SUCH
A PURSE PERVASIVE PROBLEM. THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO TO CLEAR TO
CONTINUE STATE OF EMERGENCY
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY THREE.
THIS POLLUTION IMPAIRS THE
QUALITY OF WATERS THREATENS
LIFE AND PROPERTY DESTROYED
HABITATS AND EFFECTS WRECKED
RECREATIONAL ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES FOR RESIDENTS AND
VISITORS. IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE
THAT IN THE NINETEEN TWENTIES
AND THIRTIES THERE WAS. A
SALMON CANNERY ON THIS RIVER.
DESPITE THE DECADES OF WORKING
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TOWARDS A SOLUTION THEY HAVE
REPEATEDLY FAILED TO STOP THIS
MASSIVE POLLUTION THIS
DISCHARGE AND PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES. UNDER WATER
TREATIES UNDER DIFFERENT
AGREEMENTS BETWEEN OUR
RESPECTIVE COUNTRIES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OF THE
UNITED STATES HAS
RESPONSIBILITY TO GUARD AGAINST
THIS PROBLEM. SO WE ASKED THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE SEND
YOU WATER BOARDED UP. TO CREATE
A LAWSUIT AGAINST THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT HAPPENED LAST
YEAR THAT LAWSUIT IS ON GOING.
AND THEY ARE SUING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR VIOLATIONS OF
THE CLEAN WATER ACT AND THE
CONTINUED POLLUTION POLLUTION
OF STATE WATERS UNFORTUNATELY
THIS PROCESS IS FAR TOO LATE
THE IN THE LIVES OF PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. CANNOT CONTINUE TO
BE IN DANGER AS A RESULT OF
CONTINUED EXPOSURE TO DANGEROUS
TOXINS AND PATHOGENS. OUR
RESOURCES IN DANGER SPECIES
COULD NOT SURVIVE CONTINUED
EXPOSURE TO WASTEWATER ANOTHER
TRASH ESPECIALLY WITH THE LONG
LIST OF ENDANGERED SPECIES THAT
WE HAVE IN THIS AREA THE CALL.
THIS COMMUNITY THEIR HOME OUR
ECONOMY CANNOT CONTINUE TO BE
STUNTED BY CONSTANT BEACH
CLOSERS AT DRIVE DOWN THE VALUE
OF OUR HOMES TO PREVENT ACCESS
TO OUR CULTURE RESOURCES. AND
GIVE OUR OF RICK CREATORS
HEPATITIS AND OTHER INFECTIONS.
IN THE PAST THIS ISSUE OF THIS
CHARGE WAS EXACERBATED BY WHAT
WEATHER CONDITIONS AND OTHER
MATTERS. THIS YEAR TO THE STATE
BUT YOU WERE ABLE TO LOCATE
FIFTEEN MILLION TO ADDRESS THE
ONGOING CRISIS IN THAT THE ONE
RIVER BUT THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
DEMANDS ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
THAT IS WHY I'VE INTRODUCED US
ARE FIFTY SEVEN WHICH WOULD
URGE. THE ADMINISTRATION
EXPLORE YUSHIN AVAILABLE STATE
RESOURCES WHERE FEASIBLE TO
ADDRESS THE ONGOING CRISIS AT
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER. IN ORDER
TO INSURE ENSURE THE LONGEVITY
OF OUR STATE'S WATERWAYS IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE DEDICATE
RESOURCES TO PROTECTING ONE OF
CALIFORNIA. OF CALIFORNIA'S
MOST. VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I BOTH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR WISH
TO DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALAN. BY. LETTER I
ATKINS HI BATES HI BILL I
PURCHASED BY BREVARD I KELLY AT
ALL HI CHENG I. DELI I DOT. HI
THERE ALSO I GOT JOHNNY I
GLAZER BY GONZALEZ BY GROWTH I
HURTS BERG. I HILL I WAS SO. I
TITLE. BY JACKSON HI I JONES
LABOR I'M ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL
HI MONEY BY MORE LOCK OUR
MORALE. THE REAL BY. NELSON I
PAN HI FORTINO HI ROSS. RUBIO.
ROSS I REVEAL I SKINNER BY
STERN BY STONE. I AMBERG
BOBCATS HE BY WINNER BY WILKE
HI. ICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MOVING ON
NOW TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
FIFTY NINE. SENATOR MORALE ARE
YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM FIFTY NINE. PASS ON FILE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTEEN FARO ITEM ONE
SEVENTEEN. THIS IS A BILL BEING.
A MANAGE BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
NOT AT HIS DESK WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
NINE FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY NINE.
SENATOR MCGUIRE. PASS ON FILE.
PAST TEMPORARILY ALL RIGHT FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY TWO SENATOR ON
BURKE. ARE YOU PREPARED TO
PROCEED ON FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
TWO. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR NUMBER
WILL BE. PRESENTING FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY TWO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SOME OF THE FIVE
NINETY FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER
SAUCE AN ACT RELATING TO
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE SENATOR
UMBERG THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT A B. FIVE NINETY FOUR
ON BEHALF OF SIMPLY MEMBERS
SILAS BY THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADOPT
GUIDELINES BY JANUARY ONE. WO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE TO GOVERN
THE USE AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE AND
STATE GOVERNMENT. IT OFF ALSO
AUTHORIZED DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY TO DESIGNATE A
POSITION WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT.
TO ADVISE THE DIRECTOR ON
STRATEGIC PLANS POLICIES
STANDARDS RELATED TO.
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE I ASK
FOR YOUR RIVAL. DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SENATOR BORCHERS THANK YOU
MADAM RESIDENTS WANTED TO
COMMEND THE FLOOR MANAGER AND
OF COURSE THE AUTHOR OFFER
BRING THIS ITEM FORWARD SERVING
ON THE A I. SUBCOMMITTEE WITH
THE SOME MY COLLEAGUES I THINK
WE NEED TO APPRECIATE THAT THIS
IS NOT JUST THE NEXT CHAPTER OF
TECHNOLOGY THIS IS A
FUNDAMENTAL EVOLUTION. AND THE
SOONER WE GRAPPLE IN BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE IS GOING TO MEAN
NOT ONLY FOR AMERICA BUT THE
RISING POWERS ELSEWHERE IN THE
WORLD THE BETTER OFF WE WILL BE
SITUATED SORT. I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THIS BEING FORWARD
AND BRING OUR ATTENTION TO THIS
MATTER. THANK YOU SIR BOARD
JUST ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING AND HEARING ON ICE
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO ASSEMBLY
THE MEASURE PASSES. A COLLEGE
I'M GOING TO GO THROUGH AND
IDENTIFY THE NEXT FIVE ITEMS SO
THAT ALL AUTHORS SIR FLOOR
MANAGERS WILL BE PREPARED THEY
ARE ONE EIGHTY EIGHT. ONE
NINETY FOUR ONE NINETY FIVE TWO
OH SIX AND TWO OH EIGHT SO IF
ONE OF THOSE IS YOURS PLEASE BE
AT YOUR DESK PREPARED TO
PRESENT WHEN THE ITEM IS CALLED
AND NOW WE'LL GO TO FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT. WHICH IS A
MEASURE THAT SENATOR BELL WILL
BE PRESENTING MR SECRETARY
PLEASE READ A SOME A BILL SEVEN
AWAIT BY ASSUMING MEMBER
FRASIER AN ACT RELATING TO
TRAFFIC VIOLATORS SCHOOL
SENATOR BELL MADAM PRESIDENT
THIS BILL CLOSES A LOOPHOLE
THAT ALLOWS. THESE ONLINE
TRAFFIC VIOLATORS SCHOOLS TO
CREATE HUNDREDS OF SIMILAR NAME
SCHOOLS TO DOMINATE. THE DMB
REFERRAL LIST LIKE. SINGLE A
DOUBLE TRIPLE A QUADRUPLE WAY
ALL IN A ROW SO THAT. YOU GET
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT. SO
THESE CHANGES IT SO THAT THE
PARTICIPANTS IN THE STATE
PROGRAM WILL RANDOMLY SELECT
ONE OF THE REGISTERED SCHOOL
CRITERIA TO PREVENT THE
MANIPULATION OF THIS LIST
APPROVED BY DMV IN THE STATE
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
ANSWERS A CONSUMER CAN ACTUALLY
WORK WITH AN ACTUAL HUMAN
BEING. IF THE EXPERIENCE ANY
ISSUES AND OTHER TRAFFIC
VIOLATORS SCHOOLS I
RESPECTFULLY OUTS AND I BOTH.
BE SURE TO BUILD A BETTER
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS HI BATES.
NOBEL I PORGES. RADFORD I CARRY
IT ALL I CHANGED HI DOLLY HI
DODD EITHER ALSO I GOT JOHNNY.
HI GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE.
HERTZBERG. HI HILL HIGHWAY SO
BUYER TADO I JACKSON HI I JONES
LABOR I AM A CHOIR HI MITCHELL.
BY MORNING I'M MORE LARK MORALE
NO NELSON. NO PAN. HI FORTINO I
ROTH BY RUBIO. I SKINNER BY
STERN BY STONE NO BERG. HI WHAT
COUNTY BY WINNER I WILL HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME. GORGEOUS NO.
GROVE. JONES MORE LOOK MORE
LIKE O ICE THIRTY TWO NO SIX
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY FOUR
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. A SYMBOL
NINE FORTY FOUR BY A SEMI
MEMBER QUIRK AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES CENTER
WHY KOWSKI MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES AB NINE FOUR FOUR
WILL REQUIRE COUNTIES THREE NEW
CAL WORK BENEFITS TO AN
ELIGIBLE SPONSORED INDIGENT NON
CITIZEN IF THE COUNTY
DETERMINES THE SPONSORED NON
CITIZEN WOULD GO HUNGRY. AND
HOMELESS WITHOUT IT THIS CHANGE
ALIGNS CAL WORK EXCEPTION
PROVISIONS SIMILAR TO THOSE
WHICH ARE USED BY CAL FRESH TO
THE EXTENT PERMITTED UNDER
FEDERAL LAW IT HAS ENJOYS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR. WHITE HOUSE
SKINNY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM. SITTING IN HEARING
NONE IS THERE ANY OBJECTION IS
IT TO SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING AND HEARING
ON ICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY FIVE SENATOR BRADFORD.
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY FIVE. ARE
YOU PREPARED TO PROCEED. ALL
RIGHT VERY GOOD MR SECRETARY
PLEASE READ A SEMI BILL NINE
SIXTY TWO BY A SEMI MEMBER
BURKE AN ACT RELATED TO
HOSPITALS SENATOR BRADFORD YES
I'M HERE TO PRESENT A B. NINE
SIX TWO ON BEHALF ASSEMBLYWOMAN
BURKE MAYBE NINE SIX TWO
REQUIRES HOSPITALS WITH OVER
FIFTY MILLION OPERATING
EXPENSES TO FOLLOW AND REPORT
WITH THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE
HEALTH PLANNING AND
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY IN EFFORTS
TO INCREASE DIVERSITY SPENDING.
THE BILL AIMS TO INCREASE
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY FOR STATES
WOMEN ALL MINORITY OWNED L. G.
B. T. INVESTOR OWNED BUSINESSES
BY REQUIRING HOSPITALS TO TAKE.
A DEEPER LOOK INTO THEIR
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY PROCUREMENT
EFFORTS SIMILAR WHAT WE'VE DONE
FOR THE LAST THIRTY YEARS AND
OUR UTILITY SPACE THE BILL DOES
NOT ESTABLISH QUOTAS IT ONLY
ENCOURAGES HOSPITALS TO ENGAGE
WITH MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITIES. THAT THEY SERVE
DIRECTLY SERVE THE COMMISSION
ESTABLISHED IS IN THE BILL
WOULD ASSIST HOSPITALS BY
PROVIDING ADVICE AND
RECOMMENDATIONS. ON THE BEST
METHODS TO INCREASE PROCUREMENT
WITH DIVERSE SUPPLIERS WITHIN
THE HOSPITAL INDUSTRY. THE
AUTHORS WORK WITH OPPOSITION
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS TO GET
THE CURRENT FORM OF THE BILL BY
TAKING THE MEASUREMENTS THAT
RAISE THE DOLLAR AMOUNT PRESS
ROLE IN ADDITION TO EXCLUDING.
POSITION PROFESSIONAL FEES FROM
THE DEFINITION OF OPERATING
EXPENSES. AND IMPERATIVE IN
THIS STATE THAT WE TAKE STRIDES
TO IMPROVE DIVERSITY OP
PROMOTING ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR ALL OUR
PEOPLE I REQUEST FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR BREAD FOR DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALAN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS BY
BATES NOBEL. HI PORGES NO
BRADFORD I CAN BE AT ALL. CHANG
NO DELHI NOTE DODD EITHER
ALTHOUGH I GOT JOHNNY. GLAZER
GONZALES BY GROVE. NO HERTZBERG.
HILL HIGHWAY SO I TACO. JACKSON
HI I JONES LABOR. TIME ACQUIRE
BY MITCHELL. BY MORNING I'M
MORE LOCK NO MORALE NO NELSON.
NO PANTS HI FORTINO. BY ROTH BY
RUBIO I SKINNER BY STERN I
STONE. NO NUMBER. HI IRA CASKEY
BY WINNER I WILL NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ALAN. HI
COPYRIGHT BY. DOES JOHNNY BY
GLAZER BY HERTZ BURKE. PATADA
HI JONES. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME
HERTZBERG HI JONES ALL EYES
TWENTY NINE KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM. TWO
OH SIX SENATOR MOANING MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. A SEMI
BUILT TWELVE THIRTY TWO BY A
SEMI MEMBER GLORIA AND ACT
REALLY INTO ENERGY EFFICIENCY
EXCUSE ME CALLING SO IF YOU
HAVE A CONVERSATION WOULD YOU
TAKE IT OVER TO THE SIDE PLEASE
SO THAT WE CAN SEE EVERYBODY IF
pACCESS. TO ALL MEMBERS THANK
YOU SENATOR MINING. THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. CALIFORNIA'S
LOW INCOME WEATHERIZATION
PROGRAM. PROVIDES LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS WITH ENERGY
EFFICIENCY. AND WEATHER IS
ATION UPGRADES THAT REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
IMPROVE QUALITY OF LIFE.
HOWEVER THE PROGRAM SHOULD NOT
HAVE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
FOR RENTERS WHO PARTICIPATE. A
B. TWELVE THIRTY TWO REQUIRES
THE COMPLETION OF A
COMPREHENSIVE ASSESSMENT. OF
THE IMPACTS OF THIS PROGRAM ON
THESE FAMILIES. THE STUDY IN A
B. TWELVE THIRTY TWO WILL
IDENTIFY TRENDS IN RENT
INCREASES AND EVICTIONS TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
DISPLACEMENT. THAT MIGHT OCCUR
AS A RESULT OF THE INVESTMENTS
MADE BY THE LOW INCOME.
WEATHER'S STATION PROGRAM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORNING
TOURNEY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALAN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS HI BATES HI BILL I
BARGES BY BRADFORD. I CARRY IT
ALL HI CHENG I. DELI. DOT. I'D
RATHER I GOT A JOURNEY BY
GLAZER BY GONZALEZ OUR GROWTH.
BY HERZBERG I HILL. I FEEL LIKE
WITH A HIGHER TITLE BY JACKSON
HI JONES LABOR. I'M ACQUIRE HI
MITCHELL. BY MONEY I'M MORE
LOCK I'M A REAL. BY NELSON. PAN
FIVE FORTINO HI ROSS BY RUBIO.
BY SKINNER I STERN BY STONE.
STONE HI NUMBER. OUR CASKEY BY
WINNER I WILL HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME DAILY HI. JONES NELSON. NO
FLY OUR EYES THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM TWO OH EIGHT.
SENATOR HER TITLE. MR SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SOME OF BILL TWELVE
EIGHTY SEVEN BY SOME IN THEM
AND IS THERE IN AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES
SENATOR HER TITLE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I'M
PRESENTING AB TWELVE EIGHTY
SEVEN THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
DEVELOPER CENTER EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND FOURTEEN NINETEEN. TO
CONSIDER THE MERITS OF
UTILIZING A N WRONG DOOR
SYSTEM FOR ASSESSING OLDER
ADULTS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. AND CARE GIVERS
TO OBTAIN ACCURATE INFORMATION
AND TIMELY REFERRALS TO
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS. THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE CONSIDERATION OF A
UNIVERSAL TOOL AND PROCESS THAT
IS CAPABLE ASSESSING INDIVIDUAL
NEED FOR LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORT. MANY OLDER ADULTS
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES FACE DIFFICULTY
IN ASSESSING THE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS THAT THEY NEED TO LIVE
ON THEIR OWN TERMS AND IN THE
LEAST RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT.
THEY OFTEN DON'T KNOW WHERE TO
TURN TO HELP TO FIND SERVICES
THEY NEED A WRONG NOTE DOOR
SYSTEM. WOULD HELP PEOPLE
NAVIGATE PROGRAMS TO FIND THE
LONG TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
THE NEED. AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE SENATE REFLECT TECHNICAL
SYSTEM FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND HAS
RECEIVED. NO NO NO VOTES. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIVEAU
THANK YOU SENATOR HER TITLE.
DEBATER DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SHOOTING IN HEARING ON
ICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. COLLEAGUES
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP THE
FOLLOWING FOUR ITEMS AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK AND LIFT
THE CALLS ON THOSE THAT ARE
STILL PENDING. THE FOLLOWING
ITEMS OR FILE ITEM TWO TWENTY
THREE. TWO TWENTY FOUR. TWO
THIRTY SEVEN. AND NINETY NINE.
SO GOING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
TWO TWENTY THREE. SENATOR RUBIO
THANK YOU PRESIDENT A MEMBER IF
YOU CAN'T GIVE ME TOO. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE THREE ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN NINETY ONE BY SOME
REMEMBER COOLLY AN ACT RELATING
TO THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
SENATOR RUBIO THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU BUT TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT A BE FIFTEEN
NINETY ONE AB FIFTEEN NINETY
ONE AIMS TO STRENGTHEN
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OF THE
CREATION OF A MODEL INSURANCE
POLICY. DEVELOPED BY THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS IN
ORDER TO REGULATE SUCH A LARGE
SOPHISTICATED INDUSTRY THE
STATES GENERALLY WORK TOGETHER
THROUGH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONERS TO COORDINATE
POLICY THROUGH THE ANY I SEE
STATE INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS
ACT IN LARGE PART OPERATING
UNDER A DELEGATION OF AUTHORITY
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH OF
INDIVIDUAL STATES. AB FIFTEEN
NINETY ONE STRENGTHENS LET
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT BY
HELPING THE LEGISLATURE STAY
CURRENT ON POLICY DEVELOPMENT
RECEIVE PERIODIC UPDATES ON
STATE LAWS THAT INCORPORATE
EXISTING AND IT I SEE RULES
STANDARDS AND PROCESS SEES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. SEEING AND HEARING. NONE
IS HER NAME ACTUAL SUBSTITUTING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE ICE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE MEASUREPASSES FILE
ITEM TO TWENTY FOUR SENATOR
HILL MISTER SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ. A SEMI BILL FIFTEEN
NINETY SIX BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS AN
ACT RELATING TO HAZARDOUS
SUBSTANCES SENATOR HILL THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
AV FIFTY NINETY SIX ADS FENTON
ALL TO THE METHAMPHETAMINE
CONTAMINATED PROPERTY ACT OF
TWO THOUSAND FIVE IN ORDER TO
SET INTERIM CLEANUP STANDARDS
FOR FENTON ALL CONTAMINATED
PROPERTY. AND PROVIDES
DIRECTION TO LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICIALS FOR THE OVERSIGHT AND
CLEAN UP OF SENTINEL
CONTAMINATED PROPERTIES WITHOUT
ESTABLISHING PROCEDURES AND
STANDARDS FOR CLEAN UP OF
FENNEL CONTAMINATED PROPERTIES
INNOCENT PEOPLE ARE AT RISK OF
BEING HARMED FROM THE RED
RESIDUE THAT IS LEFT BEHIND BY
THESE CHEMICALS WHEN THE
PROPERTIES ARE RENTED OR SOLD
WITHOUT BEING ADEQUATELY
DECONTAMINATED THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION. TO THIS MEASURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
COLLEGE THANK YOU SENATOR HILL
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE IS FOR ANY
OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING ON ICE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM TO THIRTY SEVEN
TO THIRTY SEVEN SENATOR GAL
JOHNNY. PASS ON FILE. FILE ITEM
NINETY NINE WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO FILE ITEM NINETY NINE.
SENATOR HERTZBERG MR SECRETARY
PLEASE READ WERE ON FILE ITEM
NINETY NINE SUBMIT BILL FIFTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR BY A SEMI MEMBER
QUIRK AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTRICITY SENATOR HURTS FOR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THIS
BODY HAS OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS HEARD NUMEROUS BILLS
DEALING WITH CHALLENGES THAT
WE'RE FACING IN DELIVERING
ENERGY AS WE CONVERT TO A D.
CARBONIZED RENEWABLE SYSTEM. WE
NOW HAVE 44% 44% OF NON
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY OF
PROVIDERS OF HIS MEAT DON THE
FOLKS THAT USED TO BE PART OF
IT THE I. O. U.'S OR NOT NOW
WHETHER IT'S TWO C. C. A.'S OR
OTHER MECHANISMS. SO AS WE DEAL
WITH THIS CONVERSION THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE ARE ARE
FEW ONE OF COURSE IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE LIKE THE LIKE
STAY ON ALL THE TIME. WITH THE
ENERGY BALANCING DIFFERENT IT'S
VERY CHALLENGING TO MOST
IMPORTANTLY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE PEOPLE WHO REMAIN ON THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES LOAD
SERVING AS LOAD SERVING
ENTITIES DON'T BEAR AN UNFAIR
BURDEN ON COST. AND SO WHAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORK IS SEEKING
TO DO HERE IS TO REQUIRE A BE
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR REQUIRES
LOAD SERVING ENTITIES TO PAY
FOR INDIRECT COSTS THAT THEIR
PORTFOLIOS MAY IMPOSE ON THE
SYSTEM AS THEY BEGIN TO
CONVERT. THIS YOU'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO SEE OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS MORE MORE
LEGISLATION AS WE CONTINUE TO
TRY TO TWEAK THIS AND GET IT
RIGHT I UNDERSTAND THE ROLE OF
THE P. YOU SEE WHAT SHOULD AND
SHOULDN'T BE. HARD TO
UNDERSTAND RESOURCE ADEQUACY
PROVIDERS OF LAST RESORT
CENTRAL PROCUREMENT TERMS
YOU'LL HEAR AGAIN AND AGAIN BUT
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE
AGAIN WE HAVE BEEN GRAPPLING
WITH THIS THERE'S BEEN A
TREMENDOUS NUMBER OF ABOUT A
LITIGATION BEFORE THE P. UC.
DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE OF
FAIRNESS AND COSTS THIS IS
ANOTHER EFFORT BY MR CORK TO
ACHIEVE THAT OBJECTIVE I ASK
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS SO. ITEM SEEING AND
HEARING NONE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. THERE IS
AN OBJECTION SO WE WILL CALL
THE ROLL MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN.
ARCHULETA BY ATKINS. BY BATES.
HI BILL. BY BURGESS BY BREVARD.
CUBBY HI CAN BE AT ALL I CHAIN
HI DOLLY I DOG I'D RATHER I GOT
JOHNNY HI GLAZER. GONZALEZ.
GROWTH BY HERZBERG BY HILL I
WAS SO TIRED TADO HI JACKSON HI
BY JONES LABOR. I AM A CHOIR HI
MITCHELL BY MONEY. I'M MORE
LOCK I'M A REAL. BY NELSON. PAN
HI FORTINO HI ROSS BY RUBIO. I
SKINNER STERN. STONE I AMBERG
HI WHAT COUNTY. WINNER. I WILL
HI. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME ALAN.
GLAZER GONZALES HI. JONES
NELSON. HI HI SKINNER STERN
WHAT CASKEY. OUR EYES THIRTY
FOUR AT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES COLLEAGUES WERE GOING TO
GO BACK AND LIFT THE CALLS AND
THEN WE WILL GO BACK TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS AND I THINK WE
ARE JUST ABOUT DONE. SO LET US
LIFT THE CALLS. STARTING WITH.
FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE. ALAN HI.
ATKINS BY BATES BY. ZERO I
CHANGED BY GONZALEZ BY TADO. I
JONES NELSON. NEWS TONIGHT FIVE
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN
BATES. GORGEOUS DOT HI. GLAZER
NO GONZALEZ. BY GROVE NO.
JACKSON HI BY JONES MORE LOCK.
MORALE NELSON. NELSON I. ONE
MORE TIME PLEASE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM
THIRTY THREE. ALAN BATES
GORGEOUS. JONES MORE LOCK
MERRELL. VICE THIRTY KNOWS FOR
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM THIRTY.
WE HAVE LOOKED AT ALL THE CALLS
IN VERY GOOD. BACK TO MOTION
TION RESOLUTIONS SENATOR
HERTZBERG. YOU ARE MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THERE IS A
LETTER AT THE DESK REQUESTING
WITHDRAWAL OF ASSEMBLY MEASURE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO FROM THE
RULES COMMITTEE AND ORDER THE
MEASURE TO THE SECOND READING
FILE. SURE ANY OBJECTION. THERE
IS AN OBJECTION. WE WILL HAVE
TO TAKE A ROLL CALL ON THIS
SENATOR HERTZBERG IS ASKING FOR
AN IPHONE SENATOR GROVE IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. TWENTY
ONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
HI ARCHULETA. HI ATKINS BY
BATES NOBEL BY PORGES NO
BRADFORD. BY KELLY AT ALL HI
CHAIN NO DELHI NO DONT. HAIDAR
ALSO I GOT JOHNNY HI GLAZER BY
GONZALEZ I GROVE. NO HERTZBERG.
HI HILL BY WHISTLE BUYER TADO I
JACKSON I JONES LLEVA TIME
ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL BY MORNING
I'M MORE LOCK NO MORALE NO NO
SIN NO PAN HI FORTINO HI ROSS
BY RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN. BY
STONE NOVEMBER. OUR CASKEY I
WINNER BY WILL. NO HI IS TWENTY
NINE KNOWS TEN THE MOTION
CARRIES. AGAIN UNDER MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
RESOLUTIONS WILL BE WITHDRAWN
FROM. EXCUSE ME THE FOLLOWING
MEASURES WILL BE PLACED ON
TODAY'S SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR. FILE ITEMS.
272-831-3230. FOUR THIRTY FIVE
THIRTY SIX THIRTY SEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT THIRTY NINE FORTY FORTY
ONE F
C. R. FIFTY ONE SENATE BILLS
TAN. SIR LET'S HAVE THE SECTOR
READ VERY GOOD SECRETARY PLEASE
READ THE BILLS. I WAS DOING
OKAY BUT IT'S BETTER TO HAVE
THE SECTOR DO IT. WE'LL NEED A
MINUTE OR TWO HERE. RIGHT NOW.
ALL RIGHT WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
UP THE SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR
NOW UNDER UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
THE BILLS SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY ONE SENATE
BILL. 1-016-729-4330.
835-942-8430. 944-094-8750 FIVE
THIRTEEN. SIX ELEVEN AND SENATE
BILL SEVEN FIFTY ONE. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE ICE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. AGAIN
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR SEPTEMBER THIRD
THROUGH SIX TWENTY NINETEEN
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED
BY THE MINUTE CLERK. ANY OTHER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS SENATOR
BATES FLOORS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM OUR PRESIDENT AND OUR
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE FILE ITEM THREE ELEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE ONE FIVE TWO THE
INACTIVE FILE. SO NOTED THAT
WILL BE THE ORDER SENATOR BELL
FOR WHAT PURPOSE SIR EMOTIONS
RESOLUTION WITHOUT OBJECTION AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR LIKE
TO MOVE THE A. B. FOUR TWO NINE
FILE ONE SEVEN EIGHT. TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BILL THAT WILL BE NOTED.
ANY OTHER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. CENTER MCGUIRE
THE ANNOUNCEMENTS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE PRESIDENT TO BE A
WONDERFUL WEEKEND THERE WILL BE
A GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
MEETING FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER
THE CONCLUSION A SESSION IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER SESSION
IT WILL BE VERY QUICK. THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE TO FIFTEEN
MINUTES AFTER SESSION FOR
SENATE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE SENATOR MITCHELL.
MADAM PRESIDENT THIS TO ALLOW
FOR. ADEQUATE PLANNING THERE
WILL BE A BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE MEETING ON
TUESDAY UPON OUR RETURN AT
EIGHT THIRTY AM. TUESDAY EIGHT
THIRTY EIGHT A. M. THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING ANY
OTHER COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
AND IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR ATKINS THE
DESK IS CLEAR. MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU FOR AN INCREDIBLY
PRODUCTIVE WEEK I HOPE YOU HAVE
A WONDERFUL WEEKEND COME BACK
PREPARED IT NEXT WEEK FOR A LOT
OF WORK. ON INTO MY DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES LET ME APOLOGIZE
THAT WE DIDN'T GET THIS OUT
EARLIER BUT AS WE ADJOURNED WE
WILL HAVE A VERY BRIEF
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS VERY BRIEF
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS AND WITH
THAT. MADAM PRESIDENT WE WILL I
WILL SEE YOU AGAIN ON MONDAY
SEPTEMBER NINTH AT NOON. THANK
YOU SENATOR ATKINS DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS ON UPON ADJOURNMENT AND
WE WILL BE ADJOURNED WE COULD
RECONVENE. TO MONDAY AT. A LONG
FILE. ONE MORE LINE FOLKS. SO
THE CENTER WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL FIVE PM UNTIL FIVE PM AT
WHICH POINT IN TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
PLACED. THE DESK WILL BE OPEN
UNTIL FIVE PM WE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THEN AT WHICH
POINT WE ADJOURN WE RECONVENE
MONDAY AT NOON